معنا من رفح ياسر ابو هين الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي سيد ابو هين اهلا بك ما الذي
اوضحه بيان حركه حماس الاخير بخصوص ردها
على الاطار العام لاتفاق
الصفقه يعني اعتقد ان مضمون ومحتوى البيان
ترجمه ل الرد المفصل الذي سلمته حركه حماس
اي للوسط المصري والقطري ووصلت منه نسخه
للجانب الاسرائيلي والجانب والجانب
الامريكي واعتقد ان مصطلحات ومضمون البيان
الذي نشرته حركه حماس كان مقصوده منه ان
يشي بان حركه حماس تتعامل بايجابيه مع كل
المبادرات وال والطروحات التي من شانها ان
توقف هذه الحرب المجنونه على قطاع غزه
وبالتالي كان الرد كان ان حركه حما كان
واضحا في البيان ان حركه حماس تعاملت
بايجابيه وناقشت الامر باستفاضه في اطرها
الداخليه ومع الفصائل الفلسطينيه وفصائل
المقاومه وبالتاكيد ان الامر ايضا خضع
للنقاش والتشاور بين حركه حماس وا الدول
التي لها علاقه قويه او قريبه من حركه
حماس ومع الوسطاء ايضا الواضح ان الح ركه
تسعى بشكل يعني جدي و وحثيث لعدم لعدم
اعطاء الفرصه للاحتلال الاسرائيلي
باستمرار حرب الاباده الجماعيه من هنا كان
هذا التصريح عبر البيان وكان التعامل ايضا
مع الورق الرد الذي سلمته الحركه بما يعني
اطلعنا عليه من تفاصيل وبنود واضافات
وتعديلات مما يؤهل الحاله وال والوقت
الحالي للدخول في ربما شيء من المفاوضات
او المباحثات والدور
ال الكبير الذي سيلقى على عاتق الوسطاء
للوصول الى وقف اطلاق نار واعتقد ان حرص
حركه حماس ايضا كما بدا في هذه الورقه
بتوسيع دائره الضامنين
ايضا ويعني اضافه لهم اضافه الى قطر ومصر
تركيا
والامم المتحده و
وغيرها يعني واضح منه ان الحركه تريد ان
تضع الضمانات الكافيه لانجاح مثل هذا
اتفاق الاطار وجعل الامر ليس مرهونا بالرد
الاسرائيلي بقدر ما هو ما
هو ممارسه دور لهؤلاء الوسطاء في ممارسه
الضغط الكافي على الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من
خلال كل ما رشح من اطراف الوساطه او من
حركه حماس نفسها او من الاسرائيليين هل
اتضحت لك ربما ملامح هذه الصفقه بناء على
كل ما
ذكر اعتقد ان ال الرد الذي سلمته حركه
حماس وبعد اطلاعنا عليه فيه فيه تفاصيل
كثيره ومجدول وتتعلق بكل ال
المناحي التي من شانها ان تعيد الحياه الى
حد ما الى قطاع غزه وتوقف العدوان والحرب
المجنونه على قطاع غزه ال الملامح كانت
واضحه في تقسيم المراحل في جدوله ال ال
يعني جدوله اليات التنفيذ في وضع الضمانات
في افراد بنود لها علاقه
ب بصفقه التبادل لها علاقه بالحاله
الانسانيه في قطاع غزه لها علاقه
بالانسحاب الكامل من من قطاع غزه لها
علاقه بتسهيل وتسريع عمليه الاعمار وجهود
الاغاثه وعدم اعاقتها مع اسرائيل يعني كان
رد
حسب حسب ما ورد في هذا الرد المفصل
والملحق
الذي ارفقته حركه حماس في في في ردها هو
يضع الملامح التفصيليه بعيدا عن ال
الاتفاقيات الاطار العامه التي كانت
مطروحه في اتفاق الاطار في في باريس ما
وصل لحركه حماس بعد لقاء باريس هو محددات
عامه واطار عام دون بنود تفصيليه ان صح
التعبير لكن ال المشاورات التي اخضعته
اخذتها حركه حماس و تشاوره مع الكل
الفلسطيني واخضاع الامر هذا الاطار العام
وضعت فيه التفاصيل التي من شانها ان تنهي
الحرب وت تعالج كل اثاره التدميريه سواء
المتعلقه بحاله قطاع غزه و الحاله
الانسانيه فيه او فيما يتعلق بالاوضاع
التي كانت ما قبل 7 اكتوبر وهناك ايضا
بنود لها
علاقه بالقدس والمسجد الاقصى وعوده
الاوضاع الى ما كانت عليه قبل عام 2002 و
ربما جزء خاص يعني تفصيل وضعته الحركه في
ردها يتعلق بحاله الاسرى والسجون
الاسرائيليه التي تشهد اكبر حاله يعني
كارثيه بعد 7 اكتوبر منذ تاريخ السجون
الاسرائيليه شكراك ياسر ابو هين الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي كنت معنا من رفح شكرا
جزيلا لك